Guys The International 2018 was one of
the best TI's we’ve ever seen.
I mean we saw rivalries unfold, we witnessed some unforgettable plays and of course we saw the TI cycle
broken by a team with a rookie on their roster.
Now when it comes to OG’s miracle run,
I think Machine may have said it best: “Cinderella
ain’t got nothing on this.”
But of course it wasn’t all tearful moments and drama at TI8
either it had its fair share of fails and funny
moments as well, and we’ve got an entire
video dedicated just to that.
But this right here right now, is about the best of the best -- not just the best in game either
but we'll also be highlighting some of our favourite more serious out of game moments as well.
"We love the sh*t out of you."
So without further ado, here’s the absolute Best of The International 2018.
(Casting)
Man those team fights were so good watching them again makes you wanna stand up
and scream Lakad matataaaag.
But that's not all we have for you.
Oh no. We thought the team fights at this TI specifically were so good, they deserve their own section in this
video.
(Casting)
Guys as much as we love the underdog moments, the plays, the team fights from this TI.
They wouldn't mean quite as much without some of the more serious out of game moments
that came with them.
And that's true for the winners, and the losers.
So here are some of our favourite more serious out of game moments from TI8.
(Casting)
"Yesterday, n0tail he got another nickname."
"A new Chinese nickname."
"It's killer. It's like killing machine."
"Killing machine."
"That is so bada*s"
"Yeah there's a sentence about n0tail."
"Okay what's the sentence."
"I'm a killer, I have no emotion."
"This is what the Chinese community is saying about n0tail."
"I mean to be fair after that performance, and that picture that will forever live on in our minds."
"Shake your hand."
"Are we doing it?"
"I'm a killer, I have no emotion."
"You know there's a lot of teams here that have something against us as a team so,
It's not too hard to find like rivals. But I hope Optic yeah."
"You feel like there's a lot of teams against you here?"
"I mean it's just like every time we play against somebody, there's always some problem.
You know I know OG had a lot of bitterness towards us, I don't know why, I feel like
There's obviously no villain in this story, two teams came out better. But yeah I guess we just have to take it
as it comes."
"No bad blood from your side."
"No not really."
(Casting)
"SumaiL what's your motivation."
"Uh money."
"Money?"
"Yeah."
"Definitely."
"Everyone else is gonna tell you they're playing cause they're passionate. They love the game."
"No."
"I mean that's a good thing right like I'm the best at it."
"But I can also make money out of it, so it's a bonus."
"If you had to pick one."
"Money or the ego?"
"Or the title."
"What am I gonna do with a title, I'll take the money."
"What are you doing Fogged?"
"It clearly says on the schedule you're to be casting this game with me. This is meant to be our year Fogged."
"And you're gonna stand me up like this."
"I'm here on my own casting OpenAI."
"It's not gonna be any fun at all is it?"
"What's up."
"Hello."
"How's it going."
"I feel like I'm in trouble."
"You've turned up Bruno."
"Ladies and gentlemen both teams are ready for the match and to bring you the Grand Finals it's
ODPixel, Fogged, and Ben "Merlini" Wu."
"Reso was a poor guy. From a small town called Nikopol."
"And one internet cafe was the worst internet in Europe."
"So when he finished his middle school he decided I need to start my career,
I need to start playing seriously in this game.
So he moved to Kiev, the capital of Ukraine, big city.
And he was going every day to internet cafe, he was sitting next to one of his friends.
He was watching his friends play some Dota. He was trying to learn something from that guy.
And when that guy was asking, "Come on Roman bring me some water. I want to drink some water
bring me some.
Sandwich I want to eat a sandwich."
Reso was doing that.
And that guy was AlwaysWannaFly."
"Legion."
"Nyet legion."
"I do want to talk about that, is it true that Reso used to get you water?"
"Yeah, for two years."
"For two years?"
"Yeah, in internet cafe."
"And he drink my water."
"Were you surprised he agreed to do that?"
"Yeah."
"Now it is my job."
"Thank you."
"Do you feel a little bit responsible for some of his success?"
"A bit."
"Yeah a bit."
"AlwaysWannaFly was the first friend of Reso in Dota."
"He brought Reso to professional Dota. And today Reso defeated AlwaysWannaFly in a
main stage of TI."
"I was trying to hold my tears."
(Casting)
"We love the sh*t out of you."
"Like it doesn't matter if it's a fan somewhere or a distant relative, or anybody that's really close to you it's just
having it said out loud, I mean it makes all the difference in the world."
"In a way it's the only way we can help carry this burden for you."
"As much as we can."
"I mean it has made a difference, it's crazy how different it is."
"Thank you for coming out the Netherlands though."
"It was great, I love your family."
"Yeah, I'm sure they love you but you did make every single one of them cry."
"Sorry."
"Godz I didn't think there was anyone more teary than me on this."
"I think you might have beaten me buddy. You alright?"
"Okay, I think we'll move on."
"But thank you. Sheever, thank you."
"Alright I'm gonna steal the cheese, screw all of you."
"Hey hey hey."
"I am Dutch if anything."
"Oh yeah that's right the Dutchies like their cheese."
"Bon appetit my queen."
Well guys that's all we got for you on this episode of Best Of.
Now let me tell you, this video could have been about twice as long. I mean what a TI.
We saw the cycle broken, and the Aegis of Champions lifted by a rookie no less.
Alongside of course our little flower n0tail.
Now if you want more help fighting the post-TI blues. I suggest you go ahead and echoslam that subscribe
button.
So you know exactly when we publish more TI and Dota 2 content.
Thanks for watching. If you want more great content just like this, be sure to hit the subscribe button.